Have you ever wondered how flies land on the
ceiling?
Well, wonder no more.
A popular notion of how they accomplished
this used to be that the flies would do a
half barrel roll sideways just before landing
on the ceiling and then let their momentum
carry them the rest of the way up.
This was shown to be incorrect when, in 1958,
Natural History Magazine took and published
photos of flies landing on the ceiling.
What is actually happening here is that as
the fly approaches the ceiling, flying normally,
it extends its forelegs above its head and
grabs the ceiling with its front feet.
It then uses its momentum to swing the rest
of its body up until all its legs are firmly
attached to the ceiling.
At this point, you might be asking how they
manage to hold on to the ceiling with gravity
pulling them down.
Scientists used to think that the little hairs
on the fly’s feet allowed them to grip tiny
cracks in surfaces they walked on.
However, in 2006, researchers at the Max Planck
Institute in Germany discovered that the substance
secreted by the hairs on a fly’s feet is
actually a very sticky glue compound.
This glue is strong enough to hold the fly’s
weight as it walks upside down or up the wall.
In order to get each foot unstuck as the fly
walks, it has to push its foot away from itself
and peel it off the surface of what it is
stuck to.
Because this takes a lot of energy, when the
fly is on the ground or any surface where
it is walking right side up, it will only
use three of its legs to walk; so it doesn’t
have to expend so much energy unsticking all
its feet.
This sticky glue on its feet is also one of
the reasons flies tend to spread diseases
so well.
When they walk on feces, garbage, etc, the
glue on their feet picks up all sorts of harmful
bacteria and they spread this bacteria by
walking on, for instance, you or your food.
YUM!